South Korea says North Korea has fired
an intercontinental ballistic missile
into Waters between the Korean Peninsula
and Japan is the third missile launch by
Pyongyang this week Japan is called a
National Security Council meeting
following the latest test well Rob
McBride joins us live now from the South
Korean capital Seoul so uh well yet
another missile launch by North Korea
tell us more about this latest one
that's right this took place just after
seven o'clock local time in the morning
Thursday morning uh here it was detected
being launched from an area of called
Sunan that's just outside the North
Korean capital Pyongyang now it traveled
some 1 000 kilometers east landing short
of the northern Japanese island of
Hokkaido but it had a relatively long
flight time it's reckoned to be about
the longest ICBM launch by North Korea
so far around nearly 70 minutes it is
reckoned that it reached a very lofty
trajectory in altitude of some 6 000
kilometers before coming back down to
earth which would give it the kind of
range that would be able to reach the
continental United States so it is
significant and it's reckoned that this
sort of trajectory is similar to another
ICBM launched last in November which was
thought to have been a Hua song 17
that's the very latest intercontinental
ballistic missile being developed by
North Korea it has been condemned by
South Korea and it comes of course as
the South Korean Armed Forces here are
just beginning military drills with U.S
forces which always angers North Korea
and in fact when the drills began
earlier this week the North Koreans
launched a smaller missiles in protest
and Robert it comes as South Korea's
president traveled to Tokyo to meet the
Japanese prime minister I mean
presumably a North Korea's missile
program will be top of the agenda there
yeah absolutely it's a very significant
visit by president the first bilateral
mission to Tokyo by a South Korean
president in more than 10 years and it's
also very controversial in fact if we
can just move the camera back a little
bit there's been protests going on here
in Seoul about this uh about this Summit
meeting
um the two leaders uh Yoon and also
fumio kashida the Prime Minister of
Japan they are a quite aligned
politically they both take a tough stand
when it comes to North Korea but there
is a lot of politically uh pushback here
domestically in South Korea about this
visit given the long and sometimes
fraught relationship between these two
Neighbors
South Korea's president Yun tsukyol
visits Japan hoping to improve a complex
relationship shaped by successive Wars
through history and Decades of colonial
rule from Tokyo during the last century
in this social media promotion Yoon has
been trying to reach younger more
skeptical South Koreans with a reminder
about their close links to their
Japanese neighbors older people here are
more open to the idea of maintaining
warmer ties with Japan and their common
Ally the United States as a counter to
Growing threats from North Korea and the
expanding might of China it's scary
I'll say it I'm scared too like everyone
we need the help of our neighbors the
Japanese and our greatest Alliance
supporter the United States closer ties
between Tokyo and Seoul would also help
Washington's Ambitions of maintaining a
technological lead over china such as in
the production of strategically
sensitive semiconductors but Japan's
treatment of Koreans during World War II
continues to cause anger here the
recruitment of so-called Comfort women
forced to work in military brothels
still brings out protesters once a week
while other groups have demanded that
Japan apologizes to and compensates the
victims of forced labor
controversially Yoon has proposed
settling the issue by compensating
Koreans forced to work in Wartime Japan
from a voluntary fund instead of making
the Japanese company's pay
I won't accept such money even if I
starve to death why would I accept that
money for Yoon it seems it's time to
move on
Japan has changed from a militaristic
aggressor to a partner that shares
Universal values with us and cooperates
with us on security economy science and
technology and Global agendas
increasing Regional threats and
challenges giving him and his Japanese
counterpart common cause for closer ties
Rob McBride Al Jazeera Seoul